I was still at UCLA as a grad student
and I was in work in my first year
working on my PhD I mean I always knew I
wanted to teach at the college level
sometimes so I wanted to get those
required degrees in early and I just
loved College and I wouldn't let anybody
tear me out of there so I was still
working on the PhD but there was another
student there doctoral student there
whose stepfather was a director and he
asked do you have anything do you have
any stories and I was working on
something I was a head of Novell I was
working on at the time it was kind of
for the time kind of an uppity romantic
comedy so I gave it to David E Miller
was the director if anybody wants to
look that one up in film history he was
a great studio mainstream studio
director and did some really good work
but David really liked it and he wanted
to option it and work on it with me and
I said but that sounds pretty good and I
was what 20 23 24 I think I was 24 at
the time and that's what that's why I
never went back for the second year and
and beyond and I never did my
dissertation for the for the doctoral
degree because I wasn't bought out of
there and paid to write a screenplay
and I was 24 and maybe a little more
cocky than I should have been I figured
I got this knocked you know I'm I'm I'm
off and running and well the first life
lesson it was to be another eight years
before I got my next assignment my
second assignment but I was doing PhD in
theater so I had been writing stage
plays for a number of years but that's
what it was it was called the menopause
of Henrietta Luck and it was I was a
romantic comedy
I wasn't that optimistic optimistic yes
you have to be to a certain extent but
I'm also a realist I just knew I had to
do it and it was another speaking of
luck
Diane was another major major part of my
luck because this lady took a chance you
know the very very few young beautiful
women I think would be willing to take
on a guy from nowhere
who said he was going to be a writer fat
chance right but you you know put all
her marbles on that and she did and I
just it was an amazing journey and that
she took that chance was something and I
just kept working and I started to get
work okay if you're a writer in any form
in any genre if you're a writer you're
going to get kicked in the teeth I mean
that's that goes with that goes with the
territory it's just that's the way it
happens so you got to get used to
certain things you have to find that
self and peace within yourself and
toughen your skin get alligator hide
because it's coming and it is going to
come and then you just try every the
best way possible that you know how to
do to learn from it all learn from it
all and I was not by now I was pretty
shy kid basically is what it comes down
to I was not a tremendously outgoing
person at that time I didn't hadn't
mastered mastered that skill yet but I
felt I had a plan I knew I couldn't do
it by bashing on bashing on doors
kicking doors down pounding on tables
like you to exaggerate to make a point I
wasn't one of those people but what I
could do is make myself inevitable by
continuing to crank out original
material and that is exactly what
happened
I just kept riding and I just kept
rewriting and rewriting until they were
pretty darn good so when opportunities
came as eventually they did I was ready
I had scripts different genres you know
what do you want what do you want to see
and ultimately I ended up with a top
well I'm not gonna bandy names about at
this point but a top agent literary
agent in Hollywood which kind of changed
everything and you know made other
things possible and it was just because
I had a drawer full of scripts
I've written 17 feature screenplays for
remuneration you know on assignment
shall we say of those seventeen six got
made of those six I get screen credit on
five of the five I get shared screen
credit on three and sole screen credit
on two and the reason I like to run that
down for people is that is a pretty
typical career of career arc for a
working screenwriter it's not what a lot
of people coming into the field think
it's going to be no basically you end up
making your living and it can be at
times a very good living off of stuff
that is never going to get made because
whether it's made or not those are
financial decisions those are business
decisions and your original material you
crank out can be very very good and be a
good work sample but I have a number of
scripts that we're never made never
never optioned yes but never made
because they were wrong in their timing
for the business at that at that moment
so that's truly I think kind of a
glimpse of the true nature of this
business I don't think it's changed too
much since then people need to know that
who are genuinely interested in and
fantasize or see the possibility of them
becoming screenwriters they need to
buckle down for the long haul because
that's what it is
people who want to pursue this and I
definitely understand it because it I
got the bug early and I want I mean no I
knew I was a writer in the fourth grade
and I say you know it didn't I didn't
choose it it choose it chose me and okay
so that fate question is decided and we
move forward and see where it takes you
but every writer who does not come from
money who does not come from great
resources as most of us do not there are
two tracks to your life and the woman
the first is doing everything you can
with who you are and your personality
toward fulfilling that the desire then
the creative need to do these things and
write these scripts and maybe some of
them will get made and that's a separate
discussion maybe like them but also the
second track being you have to find a
way you have to build for yourself
because nobody else is gonna do it for
you an ongoing source of life sustenance
separate from your creative career you
have to build the I think build that
into your plan from the beginning
because even when you do get start
getting hunks of money it comes in hunks
and at times it can be wonderful that
can be very big hunks but when that
happens you have to really know how to
how to turn that money into income in
indefinite income I mean I have so many
friends of course it's so hard and you
struggle and all of a sudden you're
making the big bucks and and your name
is in variety it for a few times and all
that and so they run I said you know I
work so hard I really deserve this and
they go up and buy the big house on the
hill which is certainly understandable
and five or six years lady you know
they're selling it they're desperate and
selling it and they lose it because
every year is not like that it doesn't
always rain gold coins in this business
it's going to be very sporadic take what
you make turn it into income
and that's what I did what we did I
advised income real estate but something
so that you can have a life separate and
and assured I made it depends I mean
Diana and I we wanted kids we had I mean
when we had kids
pretty pretty soon pretty early on and
the responsibilities mountains you know
and you got to do both you got to do
both and it can't be done that way
one of the first things that happens
when anybody gets hired I mean in any
level in Hollywood it's an agency it's
it's a production company usually in the
first week or two somebody drops by
you're juggling the coffee or whatever
it is your your your task is and they
drop a script in front of you and they
say you know I've read this over the
weekend we tell me what you think of it
on Monday and it's all very casual and
low-key but the truth is this is one of
the most important moments of your
professional life because how you
respond to reading that script and how
you speak of it afterwards will tell
them a great deal about how useful or
not you will be to a company going
forward that is in the creative business
if I may throw a statistic at you in
1946 just after World War Two at a time
when only about 10% of the population
nation's population went to college or
could afford to go to college the GI
Bill hadn't kicked in yet you know it
started to change us but in 1946 the
America the general American population
had a reading vocabulary of 25,000 words
that's not recognition that is used in
you know an everyday conversation a
reading vocabulary 25,000 words by 1990
the average American had a reading vocab
speaking excuse me speaking vocabulary
of 10,000 words and since then I am sure
it has declined precipitously since then
that is what happened you read less you
just see images you live through images
you you know you use emojis to express
emotion and you don't need words you
don't have the subtlety of words of the
variety of the vocabulary and it limits
I believe truly limits how people can
think even intelligent people how
completely they can think and that's why
reading actual words on actual paper is
incredibly important for young writers
there is a major problem in the third
act I mean this is getting pretty
esoteric but there's a there's a major
problem in the third act of of Erin
Brockovich which there is a point a
dramaturgical point that must happen
must happen ends in films that are going
to connect with large audiences and
because of the circumstances this is a
Erin Brockovich is a courtroom drama
really it's about somebody suing
somebody so the big payoff moment what's
called the obligatory scene would happen
which should happen in a courtroom but
Erin Brockovich is not an attorney so if
it happened in a courtroom the entire
big moment would take place with Erin
Brockovich just sitting there silently
watching and Susannah grant recognized
this quite correctly so that this was a
dramatic big dramatic problem so like a
really good screenwriter does she found
a way around that that gave it the
emotional punch kept the focus on Erin
and gave it the the sense of victory and
emotion for the audience at the ending
instead of the courtroom we'd never go
to the courtroom
do you remember what yeah yeah I'm
remembering certain scenes right now
definitely yeah yeah accord the end she
was running around getting everybody to
sign right up for it because they had to
X percent 90 percent or something like
that is all the people in the town and
had they had to sign this affidavit or
something like that and she comes back
and there's these two uptown uppity
lawyers and there's this funny scene
where she basically lays out that she's
saved the day you know she's found the
smoking gun
she's got got the evidence and and it's
turned into a moment of emotional
victory for the hero with a substitute
adversary it's not I mean they're not
the real adversary PG&E is the real
adversary right
I know this is kind of a subtle thing
but it is a remarkable piece of
screenwriting to know that and to write
it in such a way that it works plus she
had been fighting that stereotypical
Uptown person throughout her working
with Albert Finney the looks that she
would get whether it was her fault for
the way she was dressed in some of the
comments but she was fighting that same
stereotype so it was like a culmination
of that at that moment yeah they are a
brilliant writers substitute for to
provide the emotion that cannot endure
these circumstances because it's a
courtroom drama and she's not a lawyer
but that can provide the substitution of
an emotional payoff for an audience and
it works it works
- trace character growth you have to the
writer doing it and anybody who wants to
understand it you know when it works
with other you know with other writers
doing it well in other films you have to
go back to certain basic questions and
the one in Erin Brockovich is what does
Erin want there is one thing and that's
what you have to you know condense it
down - unless she wants this she wants
happy kids she wants money she wants
what does Erin inside what does she want
and need and you boil that down that's
question number one this is good in
general kind of stuff when you're when
you're when you're writing a character a
lead character heroine ER or hero right
you've got to know certain things about
what makes them tick I would offer that
what Erin Brock Erin Brokovich wants is
to be taken seriously everything she
does everything she says everything she
goes back to it is about being taken
seriously and but then she finds out as
she goes along in her story she's
getting closer and closer to actually
being taken seriously
it's costing her her family she's losing
her children and her children's
connection to her because she doesn't
have any time for them anymore remember
her son she he's really getting kind of
twisted out of shape and you know he's
not happy with mom at all because she's
not around anymore
so the hero's journey emotionally the
inner journey it has to be it always has
to be hard that always has to be
difficult and you have to be able to
demonstrate it physically visibly to
demonstrate it and so you have to know
what they want and that has to come out
I mean really want their primary
defining want as a human being
and you have to know they're wound every
character that works and every character
who has character growth ultimately has
this deep inner wound it usually takes
place in the past before the film begins
but not always sometimes in in Finding
Nemo Merlin who is the hero of that
movie he the wound happens right at the
beginning when he loses his wife and 999
out of his thousand eggs to this
Barracuda or whatever fish nasty fish
eats them all up and it's this this is
his tragedy but the wound then defines
that character for the rest of the movie
until they are able to move beyond it
the wound the wound is when a person has
a wound going that deep even you know in
reality let alone you know in fiction
they tend to insulate themselves and
defend themselves by creating this
shield between themselves in the world
so nothing that horrible or that painful
can ever happen to them again that's
usually when we meet them toward the
beginning of the story this person who
is isolated emotionally isolated behind
a shield and the journey toward
character growth is them figuring out
that they have to get away from the
shield they have to lay down the shield
and face the potential hurt and pain in
the world in order to connect with
humanity and and lead a full life you
know to connect with earth again can
people and and really live a complete
life rather than just be caged up and
you know and be gone and and never have
connected with anybody else and that is
what has happened to Aaron she is behind
remember they have you have the scene
this is still in act 1 I think it is and
she's got the tiara and she's doing her
speech because she was Miss somebody
he's
miss Wichita or something like that
right once I'm point and and she said
that I thought I was gonna be somebody I
thought I was gonna be able to do
something and then she found out that
she was just treated like a dumb broad
opening chain stores department stores
and they didn't expect anything of her
and they didn't want anything of her
they just wanted her to stand there and
look pretty and that was her wound she
she didn't see that I mean she
originally saw that as her opportunity
to to break free and you know be who she
knew she could be but didn't work so now
in her life while she's desperately
trying to put food on the table for her
kids she is also desperately seeking a
way to get people to take her seriously
and that's a wonderful place to start
character growth it really is
some of the students are a bit cynical
about my lack of cynicism about
Hollywood and movies that make a great
deal of money but I I just point out
that what money means is this film
touched untold millions of people where
they live it gave them a some form of a
rewarding emotional experience they got
what they came for a storytelling here
is an instance of storytelling it worked
and that's what we need to learn how to
do because that's a language that's a
language and a craft and a ritual that
can be mastered
these comments that flow into things I
think it was it was actually was one of
your clips and somebody somebody down
there was saying I hate plot you know I
want story and that poor person
obviously is not educated about these
things because plot and story are the
same bloody thing
they are you a story is plot plot is
story maybe we can get there in a minute
or two but make those mistakes and
that's just that's just ignorance you
know and you can get educated and you
can learn the tools and how to use them
it is to be out there so I'm going to
create this beautiful big intricate
thing and not know the pieces of it it's
like going to say I'm going to create
this big beautiful house and I know
absolutely nothing about cement
electrical cabling roofing shingles
glass or you got to know all these
things before you can build a house and
I believe the same is true for really
good screenwriting
did you know for instance that there are
only four viable goals in all of
narrative screenwriting and the vocals
long yeah
when stop escape or retrieve so okay
you've got an idea for a character your
hero or heroine great you've got an idea
and they have okay now what is it that
you want where they've got to have a
goal to pursue right well it has to fall
into the category of wind stop escape or
retrieve now these are big categories
and there are many versions of each
woman many permutations of each one so
it's not like it's that cut and dried
but it will appear to a lot of people
like it's that's to cut and dried for me
but the point is this
there's only those four because those
four share something in common they all
provide a visible physical
three-dimensional goal for a motion
picture that will result in a physical
climax and obligatory scene it precludes
the use of internal goals and that's one
of the things people have to get over an
internal goal that's great
and it is separate from what drives the
movie you need a physical visible goal
each one of those four goals has a
finish line a visible finish line and a
goal like well they want to feel better
about themselves that doesn't work on
film it just doesn't work
there are only four emotions mad sad
glad and scared you haven't heard that
one yeah again there are they they are
you know there's a lot of variations or
demands med said glad and scared there's
many permutations and and and dimensions
there but the way they are useful is
like this if you are building if you're
outlining something a section a
particular section here a goal sequence
or a particular scene the thing is the
way you guarantee that it's going to
have conflict and change in it and
change is one of the single most
important we could talk about that in a
minute to change is the power that makes
screenplays either work or not work you
got to quantify it but it can be done
wonderfully that if if the hero lead
character walks stomps jumps falls into
a scene and they are either mad sad glad
or scared by the end of the scene they
have to be one of the others if they're
mad when they show up they have to be
scared when they walk away or if they're
scared when they show up they have to be
glad when they walk away because that
guarantees dramatic change within the
scene and it's a way of checking
yourself because we read a whole lot of
scenes which are just talk and they're
the same everything is the same at the
end as as it was at the beginning and
that is not a viable scene for visual
storytelling
there are 14 character Gator can
character categories that advance and
serve story story is a central character
hero or heroine who undertakes to do
something physically do something in
order to achieve a visible physical goal
by the end kind of stuff and in that
pursuit there are 14 other character
categories who serve as either helpers
or hinder vers toward that hero and they
are mean like first of all I mean the
main categories are our hero and
adversary who adversary is much unsung
and under underappreciated the adversary
is critical and and and and the point
I mean without without conflict you
don't have a story there is no story
without conflict that's just it you know
so that adversary is key to the creating
of conflict and so it puts a lot of
weight on who the adversary is so you
got hero adversary then there is a
mentor a very wide and delicious
category and you know goes back to Joe
Campbell and and the assessment of the
mythological approach stuff that there's
some of those characters I mean he
called the adversary the shapeshifter
that's some more specific usage yes its
adversary shapeshifter is is somebody
who appears one thing on the outside and
becomes something else that is one kind
of adversary but not the only kind so
and then there's mentor there's the love
interest character this is interesting
the love interest character I really go
into this in detail for folks for some I
mean the love interest character brings
depth and humanity and and and helps
augments and eases character growth
forward for the central character and it
is the least used character category of
all the grad students who pass through
here yeah it really is I I think it's
the character it gets too close to home
maybe there
experience you know in these things
emotional sensual experience is highly
limited or something what it is
something about it but that is a key
character and stories that work and you
have a romance subplot that love
interest character whoa when it's done
well it's one of the most powerful
things you can add to a story and then
there are helper follower a lions and
ants a sidekick sidekick is another
category very specific function is
played by the sidekick and and there's
there is the adversary agent see there
is one adversary adversary can only be
one one person a human being or a
personified thing a monster that behaves
like a human being and thinks like a
human being but the one thing one human
being but they can also have all kinds
of adversary agents running around doing
the bidding of the adversary there's a
group of characters called gate
Guardians and that's I would put those
people in the gate guardian category
Gate Guardian is a character who this is
this is from Campbell and the
mythological structure to gate Guardian
is a character who when first met by the
hero when first confronted by the hero
stops them says no you cannot enter here
but once the hero finds a way to
outsmart that gate Guardian it's never
brute force it's but when they outsmart
them and find a way to get around them
and continue their journey after that
the gate guardian becomes an ally at
first opposes and then assists and I and
a few more few more in there too but see
but the point is all of these characters
there's only fourteen that that help you
create a plot that help move a story
forward and any other character that a
particular writer wants to block you
know I really like this character you
know they're kind of interesting and
peppy and zippy and they talk funny and
I like it
if they do not serve the story if they
do not
helped drive the plot forward get rid of
them Aksum cut him lose them because
they have to serve a function
every time I walk into the class the
first evening all our classes are
evening evening classes and in the new
class the first-year people there for
the first semester and I walk in and
they're chattering away and trying to
get to know each other and so forth but
they haven't you know really had any
anything to do with me yet and I walk in
it was always weird and creepy because
as soon as I walk in deathly silence
falls everybody's waiting so I look very
austere and serious and I walk to the
whiteboard and I write on the whiteboard
and very very large letters write badly
with pride and then they laugh you know
everybody everybody laughs and it cuts
the ice and you know it works that way
and I turn around and I smile and I say
yes but I'm not kidding for it is a
critical importance for writers to
permanently give themselves permission
to write badly if writer's block is all
about expecting and demanding of oneself
perfection anything any word any
sentence it's gotta be great it's got to
be great no that way lies right early
death you do that you'll end up freezing
so solid you'll never write again it is
exactly the opposite writing is a craft
it's a craft and how do you how do you
participate in a craft it's a craft that
it's you that exercised with words and
it is like in in I don't know statuary
or something you start out with a big
gooey pile of wet clay and you started
mush it you get your hands dirty you
know you get down in the mud and your
mush it and squish it then you start
making choices about as you shape it the
pieces you're not gonna need and so
forth
and you go from there but you start out
with mess that's what we do as writers
we start with mess and then we make
choices first hundreds of choices and
then thousands of choices and before
we're done tens of thousands
of individual choices have been made but
you cannot make choices and you cannot
see what or choose what direction you
want your story to go in or have you
wanted to develop unless you have a pile
of words on the page so we have
exercises sometimes just let's try it
let's write as badly as we know how and
it's funny you read them aloud everybody
gets a laugh it's got stuff and what
they find out is even when they are
trying to write badly because that's
what we're doing it's this little
exercise it still comes out funny it's
still it's it's not bad in other words
they're they're funny they're cute
they're weird they're quippy but even
writing badly they're not really writing
that badly at all
writers never write alone never but what
we spend a lot of time alone in the
writing process but once we have
something then we have to and this is
important this is important to two new
writers everywhere you have to have a
circle of people you chose opinion of
material you trust it's one of the
things that happens in our program these
people make friends for life
because then they rely on each other's
judgment because everybody knows
everybody's opinion grows to become
quite sophisticated about a material and
you can always call up one of your
buddies and say you want to do a script
swap you know you read mine I read yours
and what you get back frequently is not
what you want to hear we're all children
you know we all want to say oh that is
the greatest thing isn't that great and
that's never what you hear so you're
always eternally disappointed so you
hear objective good criticism of what
you've got and I always tell them 48
hours don't do anything for 48 hours
suffer fine you stay in bed whatever you
need to do in response to what you've
heard about your material and then sit
down and read it again cover to cover
and it will be revealed to you through
someone else's point of view what you
really have and all of a sudden it's
time to start editing again and
rewriting again you will get it and that
is what has happened there is the cycle
of subjective work to re objectification
because the more you work on something
over time the more you are in it you are
drawn into it and it becomes within you
and it is about you and you think you're
doing something great and then you take
it out and you get a slap in the face or
two you get you clears your eyes it
clears your vision very very well
you become reified and you approach the
material again with clean
for another go-round and in my
experience if you really want good
material and I'm assuming we all do
there's some we just want Pat's on the
head and all kind of stuff but if you
really want the material to be good you
have to go through that cycle
subjectivity re objectification
subjectivity rehabbed four or five maybe
six times then then each time you know
it gets better and it gets a little
better and it gets a little better and
you don't want to send that anything out
it's one of the biggest mistakes people
make sending out material before it's
finished
there is no such thing as a bad
screenplay only an unfinished one and
this is something I believe truly
believe just as strongly as I believe
about writing you know you got to write
badly with pride or you're never gonna
write anything it's you have to allow
yourself to do that but I think any idea
for a screenplay that is conflict based
you know this is the essential it has to
be conflict based but any idea for a
screenplay that is conflict based can be
made to work it can and bad screenplays
if they contain some conflict they can
all be made to work it's just that
they're sent out before they're finished
and when you send something out before
it's really finished you really only get
one good shot at it you know you kind of
burn it up and a lot of good ideas of
gone to the idea cemetery because of of
making that move
for a long time for years before I
became a professor here while I was
still a full-time screenwriter I was
teaching at UCLA Extension writers
program which is the largest such
writing program in the world and its
really great really good people teach
there and it was a way to get out of the
house one night a week you know out of
my room out of my office
and I was working with people who were
really bright and really talented in
various and sundry ways they you know
great characters warm three-dimensional
super dialog that just kind of crackles
and pops but when they finally turned in
their final project at the end of the of
the quarter I guess the quarter system
there and I read their scripts they just
laid there that they were flat the story
wasn't happening or going anywhere they
would have three or four events and then
try to stretch that out over you know
110 pages or how would the whole
screenplay would be and I gave them the
books we read the books we went over it
in the structure over and over the
classic structure and and and Joseph
Campbell and all of that and yet when
they sat down to write it it just
somehow didn't gel into a concept or
command of screen story structure and
screenwriting is screen story structure
more than it is anything else right so I
went looking for you know as people do
for patterns there had to be a way to
teach story construction to not to the
exclusion of all else but focus only on
finding an objective objectified way to
teach story construction this is how you
build a house board one you know that
kind of stuff and I looked at the you
know hundreds and hundreds of films and
yes I began to see a pattern
that I hadn't heard anybody talk about
before or mentioned before or hadn't
read about before and and I kind of
codified it put it together as a
paradigm and cleaned up the questions
that it raised kind of stuff and I kept
looking and I began more and more
convinced and then I did I to prove
myself wrong I mean this was I thought
was a real important step so I went back
searching through movies that had been
hit movies that had you know emotionally
affected audiences all over the world
from pretty far back I went far back as
1929 Buster Keaton the general I don't
know if you ever saw it it was one of
his last if not his last silent film it
is you know something of a masterpiece
of the silent era same thing the same
beats the same moment the same sequences
accomplishing the same stuff so I
codified it and began to teach it in in
in the grad courses people were rather
cynical about such a thing to begin with
but what I found out over a few years of
working on codifying it simplifying it
you know packaging it in a way that was
understandable and useful as a tool
because that's what it is it's just a
tool and darn good one useful one too
one by one I won them all over and I
proved it yes it's true and it was like
an interesting experience for all of us
because again it is it is about
discovery just let me try this okay for
just just a few minutes
one of the single most important aspects
of screenwriting any long form narrative
novel writing to it just screenwriting
in particular is change things thus
everything in the story must keep
changing as it flows it got you know it
has to be different five ten minutes
from now than what the circumstances
were previously ten minutes ago it has
to keep changing and I I had came to
believe there had to be a pattern of
change and what I discovered was this
this gets a little numeric you know
there does stick with me for this
because it's it's important and I think
enormous ly useful three acts okay and
in a screenplay you've got three acts
first act in Act one I noticed there are
six sequences following one another that
I called I came to call hero gold
sequences here's the definition for a
hero gold sequence a hero gold sequence
is any two to seven page section of your
screenplay in which and through which
your hero or heroine pursues one
short-term goal physical short-term goal
only one as one step toward achieving
the overall story goal right just just
that little piece of it and at the end
of that seven or so you nothing is exact
you know but seven or so pages something
happened or some discovery is made by
this hero that I call fresh news in
other words they turn up something that
was unknown by them and by us by the
audience about what they are doing that
puts an end to that current single goal
and offers up an
ooh short-term physical single goal to
be pursued in the next step and that
there are six of these hero goal
sequences six little individual pursuits
of individual specific goals in the
entirety of act one and what we call
this many names for this plot point one
there's the the first major turning
point that kind of thing
I call it stunning surprise one when
stunning surprise one happens which ends
Act one officially and dramatically ends
Act one and kicks the hero forward
tumbling head-over-heels
into Act two I call it stunning surprise
one because that it should be I believe
the emotional impact on both the hero
and the audience it needs to be
emotional and it needs to be impactful
not abstract that always happens in here
a goal sequence six always and it
continues in the first half of the
second act there are six more hero goal
sequences and hero goal sequence number
twelve always contains the midpoint
sequence that's a separate discussion
the midpoint is a fascinating part of
movies that work and it's it's it's rich
and layered with things that go on
relative to character growth and
relative to the plot being you know
bumped up to the next level and all but
it always happens in number 12 in the
second half of Act two there are six
more wonder of wonders there are six
more hero goal sequences and hero goal
sequence 18 always contains stunning
surprise to not seventeen not nineteen
eighteen in every movie that works for
audiences in other words every hit movie
that you
analyze because it's doing something
right this is the pattern and then in
Act three it's the only act where it can
vary where the numbers can vary and in
Act three you have between two and five
hero goal sequences I don't recommend
five five is good movies have been made
with five like as good as it gets which
has to be you know one of my favorite
romantic comedies kind of stuff it has
five here we go sequences in rather
extended act three but the audience is
getting antsy and it's time to get out
by then I I the standard the average of
movies that work is 2121 here with goal
sequences eighteen four acts one and two
and then another three in act three this
is a way I know it sounds kind of weird
and mathematical at this point but this
is a way of quantifying change it tells
you in advance this must happen in these
few pages there it also goes beyond that
I mean people were asking you well and
what specifically happens in each one of
these can you nail that down in a
general way yeah I do that in the book
you know I said well these things
usually happen in here real goal
sequence number four you know that kind
of stuff but that's up for grabs and up
for people to play with but structurally
the bones are these 2223 hero goal
sequences laid out in this exact way and
they don't change
you have to get used to the system you
have I've for instance back in back in
the day back in my day there was one way
into Hollywood TV film one way and that
was through an agent's front door and
that agents front door had layers and
layers of guardians before it and that
was also frustrating you know in a
similar way but very very frustrating to
Gideon but now what you have you have a
more creative path let me put it this
way contests screenwriting contests have
now been around long enough to separate
the wheat from the chaff
you know the good ones year after year
have gotten stronger because you know
more people believe in them and the less
good ones although they're all sincere I
know they're all sincere have kind of
fallen and fallen by the wayside but the
test is this every time I hear that I
mean yes I have great sympathy for that
I understand that I remember when I was
coming up myself and what it felt like
and it was infuriating and frustrating
the number one reason why you are not
making it is the material is not yet
good enough because you if you're not
especially if you're not reading you
know that reading the stuff that's out
there you have no way of knowing how
good good has to be in order to get
noticed and coming in you have to be
better than most of the people who are
now making a living at it
in order to get noticed even but the
contests offer you know the device talk
about Ryabkov a concrete way to do that
work on it and work on it and work on it
until you've got something you're ready
to test but now pick your contests
carefully the first time you try it out
pick smaller contests more more fringing
I mean do your research they should be
decent upstanding contests and so forth
try it out let's try it out did you make
the quarterfinals or will you swept away
you know in in the first pass through
okay if that happens you have learned
something it's not ready and you keep
working on it and you keep working on it
and finally when you know you get to the
mid-level ranks and let's say it gets
your your script gets to the
quarterfinals okay but it did not make
the top 10 or top 15 fine you've learned
something more go back take a vacation
for a couple of weeks try not to think
about it then read it again make more
notes and go back to work on it and it
is a way to that's the thing see what
what what a lot of neophyte
screenwriters new screenwriters don't do
or don't pursue which is you have got to
be as a writer as a craftsperson you
must be relentless in your goal of
creating quality material
number one not enough story again it's
that old thing characters can be
wonderful dialogue can be sparkling and
even funny as heck but if the story lays
there just flat as a pancake that story
is not going anywhere it's it's a weak
story number two would be passive
central character that kids killed more
scripts than just about anything I've
ever seen and weak story and passive
central character they go together they
really go to get fit together to a
passive central character is a is a hero
or heroine you know the lead down the
middle who doesn't really do anything
and life and the story happen to them
they do not happen to anything or anyone
and that is that is a one way to put
your audience to sleep very very quickly
audience heroes have to be active they I
mean the hero is the audience you build
that you build a story so that the hero
is with lots of flaws and everything
fine yes make them human but they have
certain qualities character of the of
character and of circumstance they have
to be brave that is absolutely essential
but you can put them in you know unfair
injury we care about people who are
being unjustly dealt with they're in a
situation of danger
they're funny they have a sense of humor
that always helps loved by other people
there is this kind of list of things you
can do to keep characters interesting
that allows us to like them and once we
start seeing the nature of of the hero
or heroines major problem and the major
impossible task before them hopefully on
about page six or eight we the audience
the audience becomes one person each of
us sitting alone and we project
ourselves psychologically project
ourselves
into the hero and then word along for
the ride and if that hero doesn't do
anything or doesn't want anything and
other people do all this stuff and all
the people that come in all the
secondary characters are the witty fun
urbane you know loquacious and they're
there that and joking and funny they're
all the funny characters while basically
your central character is more or less
wallpaper
it's it's dead and that is related to
something something else which is the
adversary when that happens in a script
almost always the problem is there is no
adversary or there is no powerful
adversary adversary is so critical
people need to work on their adversary
until it is the adversary should be the
strongest person in the story I'm I you
know when I was coming up if they oh
they have to be equal they have to be
equal in power to the hero no they have
to be much more powerful than the hero
it has to look for most of the movie it
has to look like the hero has no bloody
way of defeating this adversary or
surmounting this the the problems being
presented by this adversary but they do
it they they think them and they out try
them and drive and they can make it
happen and that's a story with great
conflict with a hero who is doing things
who sucks us in emotionally that we can
ride along happily for the journey and
that's how that's how the good ones work
which that's probably more than more
than two through and made that three or
four but the the next the third I think
I would say is getting it out there too
soon okay that's what destroys most
screenplays it's hard you know writing
this a screenplay a feature-length
screen pit but heavens that's hard
really hard and it's not necessarily all
pleasant undertaking labor it it it
hurts you tear your hair out
you pound your head against the wall
sometimes literally and but finally you
got a draft oh god I did it here it is
here it is like I'm gonna get it out
quickly as I can and that's the time of
great danger you know you can't just
send it out it is not ready guaranteed
it is not ready
long long time ago in a land far away
and I was a struggling screenwriter and
I was cranking out original material
that was my thing they figured the only
way I could make my I mean I wasn't you
know a pusher and a pounder and a Yeller
and the only way I was gonna make myself
a inevitable was to keep writing and
keep writing and make myself inevitable
through a pile of good to great scripts
and that's pretty much the path the path
I took and I had a great idea about a
war that takes place at the very
beginning of the Civil War it was a
Allan Pinkerton story and I pitched it
all over town I think that a good agent
at the time pictured all 11 guys yeah
yeah good story good story we don't want
it we don't make at the moment the word
was we don't make historical pictures at
that time they were very expensive
hey costumes hey sets locations means
you know moolah so I said fine and then
my agent advised me to move okay fine we
know move on and I said you know I want
to take give me a couple of months
because I'm gonna write this anyway I
really like this story I think this is a
really good story and I want to write it
he said you're nuts but okay so I wrote
it and I really liked it and we tried it
again an in script form and you know got
the same response nobody wanted to do it
and I said okay but I know in my heart
it's a good script so I put it away it
was I forget exactly but eight or nine
years later a producer under very
charming sweet produced by the Wendy
Diamond was her name she calls me up and
says you know Eric you know that that
Civil War thing you had do you still
have that is that available is it
available would you could you send that
over at that time she was working at TNT
I was producing with with another you
know I'm strong a very strong producer
at
TNT and at TNT it was TNT that brought
back the epic the historical epic that's
part of what they were into it I guess
he was interested in you know that kind
of material or something so I sent it
over and within I don't know eight or
eight or ten weeks we had a deal
and within 18 or 20 weeks they were in
pre-production and that's one of the
ones my originals had got made so how
did they have a copy of the script again
I'm sorry you would sent it out but she
well she didn't have a copy
she only remembered it she remembered
she had read the whole script back in
the day she was somewhere else yeah she
was somewhere else doing is doing
something else but I guess the point
here for screenwriters everywhere is all
of your original material has a shelf
life it's not that you give it a shot
everybody says no and you contemplate
suicide and you put it in the closet and
carry on right it's that's not it the
cycles of what they are willing to
purchase or option or consider actually
making the cycles keep changing at one
point nobody would touch a historical
epic with a ten-foot pole and some years
later there was somebody looking for one
and my my career during those years are
23 years whatever was my career as a
screenwriter went around three times you
know hot to cold to hot to cold you know
three times three full times and every
single time when things were cooling
down things sometimes that had nothing
to do with me you know a project goes
bad and you happen to be associated with
it or have had something to do with it
and then it splashes over on you people
cool for a while every single time the
way I got back in the game was with a
new original screenplay
that's your line of defense you can't be
lazy you cannot be lazy you must
continually be working on original
material
a really bad habit that most
screenwriters have is they got a great
idea and they're cooking and they just
start writing screenplay I'm writing
screenplay pages to a boy and it's fun
but it's going nowhere ultimately
without a plan and a very well thought
out the hard work is in the outline and
it has to be a very complete outline and
you have to have confidence that all
story problems have been addressed so
the first thing you have to do is the
dirty work the outline write yourself I
would say here real goal sequences
because I happen to think it and I
happen to know that it works but however
you know beat sheet however they do it
have a very complete outline and then
good bloody luck it's it's it's a lot of
work and then I would also say yeah you
write it on a little piece of paper and
tape it above your desk write badly with
pride no no writer's block
none just write badly with pride write a
piece of piece of junk you know if you
haven't have you just sitting there
staring at the wall for an hour okay
what would you write if you were just
really writing trash really writing
garbage go for it because you never know
when the real idea is the depth of what
you are doing will be sparked you just
don't know you don't know
just when you think maybe you aren't so
good and this happened oh we all go in
cycles yeah this this should be
mentioned - I mean you know up one day
and down the next day suicidal I mean I
mean this is art this is writers you
know welcome to the club on that big
wheel the emotional journey of what it
is what we do but you are also learning
whether this art form is for you or not
along the way are you in for the long
haul
that's the only question you need to
keep asking yourself am I getting enough
food out of this enough creative food
and juice and sense of you know that
growing sense of command incremental
command of a much to be respected craft
that can be quite intricate that I'm
hooked that this is what I need I mean
it has been said that you know for
writers it hurts more not to do it than
to do it are you up for a lifetime of
all the range of emotions you are going
to be going through as a writer as an
artist does this what you want to do
really they want to be an artist that's
great but understand that it is not the
simple and easy choice to make in life
quite the contrary
but it is a fabulous fabulous journey
unlike unlike any other I think